thank you ma'am appreciate that
good morning everybody and welcome to
the final meeting of the year for our R
committee which is uh um one of the
first of the rounds that I'm going
through so um I don't know whether
that's encouraging or not for everybody
but uh it is I guess so welcome to it
CLA as always um this is a live stream
meeting and I'm not certain we have
anybody on live stream other than we are
expecting Christian a our audit director
to join us
soon um which is me oh there goes Chris
right there good day Chris how are you
um and Chris's appearance such that um I
would like to with the agenda move his
item
8.1 up to the first item after we've
adopted the minute so um V Chris I know
he's got a few things on which will
happen I move to the apologies please I
have one from rangy he is obviously out
today I think otherwise we're all here
if it's correct so I'll move from the
cheer that we accept the apologies thank
you grant all those in favor please say
I I those against it's carried any
matters of Interest people need to
declare I would just like to uh Note One
matter um and it comes up in uh in in
public excluded or what's planned to be
public excluded in
um patricians your your report where
there's a small note around risk poll in
the napia city council decision May well
be that subject to a discussion I'm the
chair of napia City's audit audit and
risk committee and for various reasons
have been inv involved in discussions
with RIS Paul so I'd just like to note
that I think the nature of the item
isn't one where that needs to prude me
from discussion but if I could just note
that please that would be
valuable uh public forum I haven't been
informed of anybody can we move and take
both sets of minutes together which is
the minutes of the 19th September and
the 25th of October 25th October ay led
by Leslie um because we were we were
just dealing with the annual reports it
looks like Tom's moved it and um Leslie
sign is there any discussion
corrections I think there was one but
I'll get it to you Liz I think I saw a
word that needed to change but that's
fine I'll put the motion all those in
favor please say I I those against
carried um there was one um action point
out of this which hasn't been done and
I'd refer you to page 9 of 63 in our
agenda which is the second resolution of
the chair developer program the next 12
months with Mr Jackson the chief
executive and the chief risk officer and
we haven't done that I'll be up front uh
having said that I'm very encouraged by
um this meeting which when we sat down
to Planet reflected what I think was
something of a more normal approach
which was based around our risk and
insurance brief um but that is still
outstanding and will be done for the new
year any other matters of action or open
items that people wanted to
raise being none I'll keep moving on now
as I said I'd like to move item eight
please up to now because we have Chris
on the uh and Jenna welcome Jenna on the
uh the zoom and CH I wonder if you'd
like to lead off please with your
paper thanks brce morning counselors um
so this the the cover paper really just
summarizes the focus of the memo from
Chris which I'll get him to speak to um
more um fome Lee um where we are at last
night we have received the draft
management letter from audit New Zealand
on the annual report so staff are this
morning going through that we will um
our responses to that and the final
letter will come back to this Committee
in the new
year and on in relation to the TP um as
I understand it and Chris will have an
update we are not in a position yet to
discuss the fee for the ltp audit but
Chris has included what would be covered
we're still waiting on the office of the
auditor general to advise what fees will
be for the ltp audit rounds so if I hand
over to Chris it's probably better for
you to discuss the the
memo thank you uh Patricia thank you
Chris in your hands any exelent points
you'd like to raise please
uh thanks Patricia thanks Bruce and good
morning everyone um I think the update
letters obviously covers two Mets of
Patricia's outline being the completion
of the 2023 audit and the 2434 long-term
plan audit planning um the update on the
audit report um I think that generally
reflects the audit opinion discussion
that we had at the last committee
meeting obviously being the two uh
qualification areas um the first being
around the evaluation movement for
2022 um reflected in the comparative
information uh second being around the
traffic counts which we
discussed um as well as highlighting the
emphasis of metad in relation to the
three Waters reform um sort of round out
the five probably of the most
significant matters that that were in
relation to the audit um the first there
being the carrying value of property
plant equipment so that just talks
briefly around the revaluation that
occurred noting that's fely stated in
the financial statements um also
outlining that no further valuations
were required as a result of
Management's fair value assessment um
checking that there was no difference
between the carrying value of assets and
the possible fair value should they have
been valued um couple of points in there
around the uh unago Central limited um
being the right down of the investment
and the loan to it um probably key
things to take away from that being we
agreed with the accounting treatment
osed to us around the right down um and
that flowing up through the group um the
second one there being around the loan
impairment um which I think it's 2.48
million um mean key Focus there really
is around the key assumptions
particularly around default rates in the
loss given default um agreed with the
assessment overall there last couple of
points are next points around service
performance reporting so there's a new
standard this year and that's just
highlighting um that following review of
of compliance with that standard that
you've complied with that um few changes
there really around the judgments that
you make and applying your performance
reporting um those are probably the key
things that sort of um that that you'll
actually see um in the annual report um
and then obviously the last one there
around drinking water quality uh
performance measures so that one there
was just uh the change in regulatory
regime occurring during the year um
equally being that that causing some
level of uncertainty around what to be
reported until Dia provided some
guidance in that space um and as a
result that meant that uh council's
expert was able to carry out their work
in in compliance with that uh guidance
and obviously we were we were satisfied
with that given that is what the sector
was
doing um I think that broadly covers
sort of the backward looking um and then
sort of moving into the forward looking
um as P outlined there uh was sort of
kicked off planning for 24 34 long-term
plan audit um the key dates of agreed
are in the are in the paper there um the
other things sort of I've noted the
there as we've kicked out a self
assessment um which is a tool used to um
sort of help us with with risk
assessment around around the long-term
plan process and make sure that sort of
that's developing in terms of the areas
of focus and risks that we see um but at
the moment I thought it was sensible
that we relay to you the areas of focus
as we see them now um and you know those
will be refined and put into um an order
engagement letter once we've had a look
at the responses to that self assessment
as well and see if there's anything more
bespoke or or specific to council um so
those areas of emphasis are covered in
the appendix to the letter um and I
think probably the other key point out
of that um out of the the body of that
um letter there is that that as P reled
to we're not in a position to issue y
engagement letter um and that's just
generally around the fee process still
being finalized by the office um the fee
is a significant component of that um
engagement letter and I can't assure it
until it's put in there so um that's
that's sort of the key hold up there so
we try to give you everything here we
can that would be in that engagement L
buy that fee
um in terms of the appendex I won't go
through that in detail because there is
a bit there um that covers generally our
scope of audit which is really driven by
the legislation of the Local Government
Act um you know what opinions we need to
provide and that ultimately drives the
work that we do um the areas of emphasis
that are in there some of them will seem
familiar um to people around the table I
think probably worth commenting on the
key what what's changed in that space um
there's been a bit of a tweak around our
focus in terms of the economic
environment um postco 19 last time it
was very sort of focused around being
within the pandemic now it's more a look
at you know inflation um adust rates and
what that means for your financial
strategy and affordability
considerations for the for the long-term
plan um the reforms Focus there also
reflects the current state of the
legislation noting there's a level of
uncertainty around that um given the
picture may change um during the
long-term plan process um and
assumptions are probably the the key
thing to highlight there is um a lifting
of the bar around climate change
assumptions um given ever increasing
public interest and and events that have
occurred over the last couple of years
so I think that's probably it that happy
to take any questions thanks Chris I
appreciate the uh response really to my
request that we have some update on the
ltp and effect what I really take is a
commitment from both sides in terms of
when the audits audit will actually
occur appreciate the fees outstanding um
which is a different matter but I won't
comment on that today um folk do we have
questions for for Chris at this
point oh yeah um just just a signal
which I've signaled once before um it
worries me that we don't have the fees
for next
year um declared before but I'll just
declare again so that people are clear
about my position I'm going to write
directly to the order General about this
I've already raised it through local
government New Zealand I've sent them a
paper um and um they are concerned so
local government on behalf of the
majority of councils are saying the fees
are escalating too quickly um and we
will approach the U this problem by
saying we just can't afford the the
increases some cases 200% over a very
short period of time um and um we will
be suggesting to the auditor general
that some of the stuff that's currently
ordered could be left uh where it's not
in an annual audit it could be in a uh
byan little trian audit which would
reduce the amount of audit work that
needs to be done and with it reduces the
cost of the of the audit so I just
wanted to signal that didn't want Chris
to find out through a third party that
I'm doing that but um so that's about to
happen thanks noie appreciate the uh the
advice I about to say the warning I
don't think it's a warning but I I think
um the office can expect a good number
of letters going to it for the situation
that se defines itself in I have other
questions on on the report
just a couple from me Cris if that's
okay look firstly thank you for the for
the management report uh the drafts
being thrown in front of my face by
Patricia this morning so um I understand
the the the sort of the direction of
Travelers comments back from you
Patricia and it'll be tied up before the
end of the year so that our first
meeting of the new year we'll see it
thank you that you given us a strong
sense of what we'll be in it um I don't
think for the committee's purpos at the
stage any of that's a particular
surprise because you've well signal that
through the course of the um uh uh the
course of the audit and and the close
out which um I appreciate couple of
questions on the
um uh uh ltp AIT and I appreciate we've
got a couple of papers both a risk paper
long-term plan paper and also in public
excluded uh the risk paper around around
it um but look I'd like to ask a general
question the core emphasis on the work
is in the five weeks starting 15 January
I'm probably looking at you Patricia we
will be ready that's I don't know
whether it's got an exclamation mark or
a question after it you can take it as
both it's an exclamation mark we will be
ready for we will be ready good good and
and that seems like a crunk Christmas
break for most folk obviously Chris and
Jina that's that's um you've agreed it
so that that's we're working to
that brilliant look at those nods I like
that can I just ask a question Chris of
you as the opinion Giver um uh under the
under the attest audit the annual audit
we you have a prescription of the
opinion Philly reflects for both the
consultation document where we do you do
most of the work the qualitative
assessment is that it gives effect to
the purpose of the act now that's
qualitative or judgmental in nature is
there anything in particular you've
hinted at climate change which you which
I presume you would expect to see
inside the um the the consultation
document does that mean if we don't have
it you would qualify because it doesn't
meet the purpose of the ACT it's
speculative but I'm interested to know
the the how you're going to exercise
your judgment over the
CD it's not an easy question Bruce
um look I think you know it's a
significant assumption at the end of the
day and you're looking at it like you
would look at any significant assumption
so I think ultimately it is a
reasonableness judgment um setting the
bar of reasonableness I think it's the
Crux of your
question um that will be established for
the sector I think as as the office goes
through its processes um I mean
ultimately we knew that bar last time
this it will be a higher bar this time
so I think it's it really is looking at
at what those those plans were um around
that assumption what you're looking to
um manage or adapt um yeah I I don't
know if I have an answer to be honest
okay look I just want to um clarify
something again I appreciate this is not
your engagement letter um but I noted um
on
our agenda 54 of 63 page 54 and it's
it's page 12 of your your actual memo um
you indicate we expect the city council
to reflect information on the impacts of
climate change identified in the last
three years in climate change
assumptions and work plans outlined in
the ltp do you ref are you referring to
the last ltp or the current ltp or the
the
ltpb it's the current one the current
one um that's saying any initiatives
that you've had in place over the last
three years and the focus and the impact
that that would have on forecast
reporting yeah with with the with the
expectation that we would then um uh um
uh we would then
have
essentially um a right debate question
in our CD as a result yep okay that's
good I just was Keen to know that was
the case um Patricia I mean I assume
that was the case but I just wanted to
um I think I wanted to us to be clear
around
here um look the um uh so look that's
that's fine we'll talk later Chris about
the issues of three Waters and bits and
pieces which are affecting this ltp
which um I'll be keing to work through
with staff um the only other thing then
and I guess I do come around back
Patricia to my question around are we
ready is the importance of the financial
model the INF the infrastructure and the
financial
strategy we're okay on that because
that's the foundation to the ltp correct
it is still it's it's the foundation we
are work in progress and we'll have as
the there's a workshop next week with
counselors that will that ties that
brings in
um all that and then I think the
December council meeting has got the
activity management plans I'm looking at
Ranna s give me a nod I'm trying to
remember the flow through and it's in
the paper that's later through is into
what the the trajectory to date is been
on the ltp and then we were still to
go brilliant that's great thank you I've
had a figure out this these guys is
there anything else people would like to
raise given I've raised a few questions
in the course of
it um there NE Patricia oh sorry just
one just one thing around the climate
change
um it seems to me when I look at other
um other councils everybody's doing
their own thing on climate change and so
you'd expect an element of uniqueness
about that because uh what we have in
South might be completely different to
what's on banks pral or whatever
um but I'm wondering whether with a new
government there'll be a change on
climate change um and what I'm just
alerting to is that um I
think central government may take away
each council's desire to do um um
standard climate change stuff do we all
go to E cars those sorts of issues um
and throw that in with the regional
councils and I'm hearing some talk about
that that maybe maybe um Regional
councils will be responsible for
geographical areas big geographical
areas so there's some uniformity of
approach to climate change so that one
council's not doing something and
another council is doing something else
and really at the end of the day we're
not making a hell lot of difference um
so just I guess I'm signaling that that
may change for us we'll have the um
whatever you want to call it the
mitigation stuff that will be unique to
each area but adaption might be
something completely different I like
the point you raised actually not
because um uh in reality it's a bit like
the annual report this year wasn't it
we're always trying to work out where's
central government going and and
actually the B is really honest now um
that actually through the course of this
long-term
plan matters may change which could
affect the final version of the
long-term plan and it's it's tough for
you Patricia and the team and
politicians but it's also tough for
Auditors which which I this this
originated not in climate change it
originated in um futur government report
yeah yeah and where they they talked
about
amalgamating um councils but there was
quite a bit of push back at lgnz level
and with some opposition MPS to say well
actually um on the issue of climate
change we want some uniformity across
the country which may or may not come
from Aman na if it doesn't
then we we should climate change sit and
and I think it will take some movement
so the movement will be that um central
government will have to suggest that the
regional councils will dictate what
needs to be done in that area so we've
got one here it would cover the other
councils but they've got to have the
test to be able to enforce it that's the
other issue which they don't at the
moment so your seor watch Grant well
take Tom's first he
Tom yeah I mean just on that climate
change Point specifically um the fact
that the Southland Regional climate
strange strategy which has been
developed by a joint committee of
councils has been led by environment
souland um in partnership with t
tamarama um the fact that it's been led
by them would mean that if there was a
the change that the mayor has um
suggested might happen it would actually
have almost no impact on us because
we're doing it collectively anyway under
the leadership of the Regional
Council thanks Tom and obviously that's
that's rich material for what Chris is
saying but actually that probably drives
some of our assp should drive some of
our assumptions around the ltp and that
should be reflected so I think you'd be
expecting to see that thank you
appreciate that that update yeah gr yeah
mine's related to um it's to cross
around how how is the information from
um has report aggregated up and
summarized through the central
government across from councils across
the country and you know are the key
issues be climate change or the lack of
all the challenges around funding for um
three Waters infrastructure those sorts
of things is it aggregated up and
presented to government in a concise way
that they really clear the issues we're
dealing with at local
government
Chris um good question um is that in
relation to uh you're talking the
long-term plan audit here in terms of
results the long-term plan audit or
historically in terms of the annual
report well I'm talking to both really
all the okay information you collect
from us how's it aggregated up the form
of view across the country around what
are the key issues that we're having to
deal with locally y so there's um
basically a sectorized report that comes
out every year on the results of the um
of the local Authority audits which
you'll see is sort of the backward
looking one um it's at a reasonably
aggregated level um but it does bring
out sort of those those key sector
themes that that you're seeing coming
through through um in your report audits
that also summarizes opinion outcomes um
across across all of the councils um
Bruce is probably closer to this cuz
he's written one once or twice in in in
a former life um and the long-term plan
is a similar report as well that sort of
reflects um on the long-term plan um
audits as well um but I'm happy to grab
you both of those most recent reports
and you sort of see it I think it's
probably the easiest thing to do might
be just to send them
through that would be good Chris i' like
could add to that thank you for
reference to my old past 10 years ago
now right each each year the auditor
general tables in Parliament a report on
his audit activity uh in local
government uh and indeed that would
normally be heard by the local
government select committee um so that
is a chance for the auditor general to
put his view uh in this case to him it
was a here my day um on on the results
um and likewise as Chris is suggesting
at the end of this long-term plan round
probably this time next year the auditor
general would similarly table a report
in Parliament with um with his views on
what he's taken out of the the audit
both operationally but actually ideally
in the way that Chris is suggesting on
the sectoral issues which are affecting
us obviously with his independent view
about those not necessarily sponsoring a
sect of VI that makes I mean if I can be
honest that makes sponsoring a sect of
view still really really important from
ourselves and from LGT so so but does is
is that jointly presented with lgz no no
it's solely that's solely the I mean the
audit General is independent he's got to
be able to do that from his own if it's
representing the collective issues that
LG should be representing us on then
you'd expect that they would be uh can't
speak from current processes um I would
have gone to a select committee knowing
what Al G were thinking probably
Federated farmers and everybody else
Under the Sun so that's a different
story but that's uh that's old process I
don't know what they do now and and
perhaps Chris doesn't either that's an o
question any other questions for for
Patricia or Chris or Jenner look thank
you for that Chris and Jenner I do
appreciate that I'd like to move to the
recommendation which we received the
report move in a second please thank you
Leslie thank you Darren I'll put the
motion all those in favor please say I
those against is carry hey thank you for
that Chris and Jenner let you get on
with your day unless you you're welcome
to stay if you want to but I'll took it
first on the basis that I thought you
might had a few other things on your
plate so thank you for being here can we
away thank you Bruce yeah worries that's
all good catch around you
guys um can I move to the internal audit
and continuous Improvement update report
please Patricia um thanks I'll take the
report as read um we are looking at um
potentially separating out what we would
uh call continuous Improvement activity
from what has been raised in audits um
whether they be the external audit or
the internal audits done by our partner
or by ourselves um we're just trying to
get the data aligned we tried to do it
for this one um we are getting um we've
added in some new graphs in there which
shows where some of those activities are
coming from and what's been closed but
we are getting um a lot of buying from
parts of the organization about
improving processes and doing those
continuous Improvement through that
team thanks Cher um we're minus Peter
aren't we because he's he needed to be
out which was fine for a good D and good
reason so um we haven't got the benefit
be here today but if you got questions
for Patricia any folk I just ask a
couple please um um just I know we
raised this the last one I shouldn't and
I don't and I looked the minutes I don't
know if I quite saw the the answer there
are some really good reports going on
there do we get to see at least an
executive summary of those reports or
the results yes we do we do when do we
see the the four that are mentioned on
page 15 of 63 so there's the r
environment environment regulatory
report audits although they may be more
audits rather than a report the payroll
access and master file the building
Control Authority which is obviously
from Focus Consulting a pre
pre one and also I noticed the oh we've
got the annual plan quarterly kpi again
there's an audit there do we have we
seen those the annual plan kpi audit
I'll deal with that one first that
literally is still being discussed that
that's been done the payroll access and
master file data audits are literally
just going through and checking any
changes to the master file that through
for payroll so I wouldn't bring those
back it's literally making sure that all
any changes to master files have been
done that was the requirement of audit
um so it's not a it's a more
quantitative transactional type one and
I'll go back and see where those uh
building and environment
ones are look I I would want to just
argue that even with an audit if there
was a one-page memo saying we've done
the master file changes um they're done
fortnightly oh are they yes after each
pay cycle there is an audit done okay
cool on the request of external audit
and internal audit it's to cover a
control you're going to do the whole
year I do it every okay right right okay
look I just think at some stage it would
be good to have a onepage memo that just
says look we we have conducted this for
these reasons and uh you know here's the
percentage accuracy or whatever it is
because in the long run as a committee
we need to understand the Assurance we
can take out of this activity um and a
it's very comforting to know it's
happening but B it be good to know at a
relevant Point what was the actual
result um just just um and it may be
unfair to ask you this um Patricia um I
appreciate the high summary of the the
highlighted summary of
um uh the recommendations just a couple
of questions the first one is legoa we
have 18
High uh those are high priority
questions around l l might be quite
recent but are we worried about laga um
we always get off say offside wrong word
it's assuming that we do get offside
with the Ombudsman but there's a high
risk of being offside with the ombudsman
um what's the direction of travel and
clearing these um those being dealt with
between Michael's governance team and
our information management team so those
are around workflows and I understand
it's also covers off proactive release
and those as well so they're being
worked through great good it's in hand
it's in hand I like that I'll take
comfort from that Michael that's superb
um does it also include what's recent
work on the the um
workshops this AIT was simply in
relation to the workflow system that we
use to monitor yeah yeah um l a request
and proactive relase um there will be
something further coming to Council on
the recent Workshop discussion brilliant
um and look the other one Patricia that
I had there was infrastructure contract
compliance um we we have nine
outstanding um again I'm just trying to
remember when the work was done uh but
contract compliance will die by um and I
was just wondering again about the
direction of travel on those even though
they're moderate rather than High um I
believe there is a work plan in place
for dealing with those um
and that should be hopefully dropped
down again great by the next meeting
well I know that Peter will be back so
we'll be able to get an update from him
then okay any other questions what I've
been asking mine yes snobby yeah a
couple of things just on table one what
what does the term made mean does that
mean that we've we've done some internal
internal audits so if you look at I
don't know building the plants we've
done does that 10 mean that we've done
10 internal Audits and one has been
closed uh there was 10 issues raised or
10 need um areas for improvement raised
during that order okay because somebody
reading this from outside would be
confused I was um and the other issue um
she wearing your
other one of your other hats um is the
issue of Information Management um and
you've raised the issue about the
workshops um and it would be good to
know as we go forward how the SEC is
going to deal with the decisions
recently given like workshops for
workshops but we have Council only
meetings here and then just a sort of
bit of an information share we got one
today um one do they need to be open
well obviously they can't be um well you
wouldn't want them to be able to think
and I'm it seems to me that 's way ahead
of other councils are doing in openness
so it's a plus for us but at what stage
do you have the ability to have a closed
meeting and and the and the advice we
got was that any of these meetings needs
to have minutes so that creates all
kinds of issues as well like who takes
minutes who's who's able to get access
to those minutes what happens if we have
a meeting for a sake to discuss
Michael's so something to do with
Michael one of the staff members I mean
you can't have another staff member
taking the meetings the the meetings so
there's a whole lot of I guess things
that run from that decision that I'm not
clear on yet I don't know how this you
might know from what you're doing the
sector um well look I'm going to hand
over to Michael really quickly for a
comment but I mean I guess the
ombudsman's made the presumption that
unless it's good reason they should be
public the question is do we have a good
reason um uh I don't know if I would
want to interpret that rule liberally if
I call it a all um because I suspect
that would still get us offside with the
Ombudsman but I think effectively you're
saying Michael we're preempting a piece
of work that you're doing in
relationship to that report there is a
report coming to the council meeting on
Tuesday setting out uh the a summary of
the report and uh these steps we'll be
taken to address certainly the workshop
issues but I can say the ombudsman's
definition of a workshop doesn't matter
what title you give it is is we staff
are sharing information with counselors
so it does not capture counselor
sessions okay it's where it only becomes
an issue once staff are involved and
staff are more than Michael so Michael
as the chief executive can be here and
it's not a workshop okay as soon as
you've got any other members of Staff it
becomes a workshop within the
ombudsman's definition okay that's great
thank you great you learned something
when you come to meeting that's great
thank you for that actually Michael
that's really that's really your stive
and helpful that's that's wonderful um
what I say Lobby you say through my
other stuff I had
two and a half might send an odd number
involved in that review and it was a
matter of consternation over many things
anyway we're there can we move to the
resolution sorry were there any other
questions nothing we can we move to the
resolution please which we received the
internal AIT and continuous Improvement
report thank you grant thank you Darren
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say I I those against that's
carried brilliant can we move to the
Financial Risk update
please to the right page um that you
again me again um so this is um covers
off just the the risks that and where we
are with a couple of things so I've
included the uh full credit rating
report from Fitch that got released on
the 9th of November um it maintained our
credit rating at AA plus with a stable
Outlook um which is similar to had said
I've gone through through the rest of
the councils that F have looked at
already this year and everyone has
pretty much stayed with that stable
Outlook even though the um environment
has some uncertainties in the future but
it's very clear that they have um when
you read the detail of their report that
our credit rating is predicated on a
very conservative debt cap we are um
much lower and have taken some very
conservative approaches historically in
relation to Deb cap
um and also on our ability to
tax so um across the sector those
councils that are rated typically are an
A or
higher might be one at a minus from when
I look through the list um a lot of at
able a um or higher and that's because
we can tax we can rate if we need more
money we have the legal ability rate and
that is what keeps that credit rating as
high as what it
is um but it also shows um and a number
of the questions that they did ask was
in relation to our cash management and
we're very clear and we've put it into
our policy that we will be quite we need
to hold a level of liquidity which our
policy has around we've said around the
20 million of liquid cash um that covers
Us for short-term need but also
we have a requirement to be able to fund
the first 40% of any natural disaster
costs under our um Insurance before the
government so we've got insurance but
there's a number of assets that we can't
insure so we need to have some cash for
those sorts of things as well so that
considers that whole conservative nature
the other aspect that I've raised here
which has come through financing
projects I put in the treasury report
for the quarter which will come through
unfortunately we've sort of half covered
it off in financing projects is that
we've still got a breach of a fixed
interest cover um we are just watching
the market at the moment the uh to see
where it goes and then we'll put some
more cover in place should we need it
we're just trying to get the final um
forecast through isn't what our Capital
borrowing will really look like coming
out to those periods so it's been there
for probably 2 years that breach and
we've just kept watching it but as
interest rates are increasing we will
need to move to more fixed um we will
need to probably go floating interest
with some fixed
cover thank you Patricia right this is a
very interesting report so Darren and
then Tom Patricia could you just help me
to understand when you you mentioned
that part of what ways in our favor is
our ability to tax surely that sets with
all councils
then it does and that's why councils
have such a high credit rating so I
think not all not all councils are
credit rated so not all members of our
GFA have got a an external credit rating
so South District doesn't have one for
instance that's not a negative on the
south District but they just they chosen
not to cost this one grand plus to have
each year so you got to have a
reasonable size debt portfolio to
Warrant the tradeoff of 50 grand for an
assessment or probably what it is these
days versus the drop in interest rate so
we get preferential interest rates based
on the credit rating so if we were to
drop and I'm going look at Andrew to AA
minus the rates go back up again with
our GFA so basis points there a few
basis points and then if you're unrated
they're higher again thank you so um
that's not in most of them there's no
one at B there's no b raded councils
no thank you Darren Tom actually
Patricia pretty much answered the
question I was going to ask which was
about um you know how does their
borrowing rates change as a you know as
a rating Falls um you did say though
Patricia that if it fell to a minus then
we would um suffer a penalty so
presumably if it fell to a a we would
not from what you said so what is how
much additional debt could we take
without us falling to a
minus what's the head room that we've
got before we start to pay more than
borrowing
rates that's a really hard one to
actually answer because it all dependent
on the assessment of the rating agency
and and their
assesses but we certainly Got The View
when we met with them that it is our
150% debt limit is a big part of it um
though we did indicate that we' be
looking to increase that through the ltp
and that Ked it so I had given them um
the headline number that we have been
talking potentially talking about and
they they have factored that in so um an
increase to where we were looking which
was still conservative which is
potentially still conservative and that
was in the draft Financial strategy at
180% was we gave them that and that
stayed at that so we can increase that
limit and
still keep that stable out look
okay so you you you VI Drew your chair
just to clarify that so you your your
view would be that we can go to
180 um without losing without dropping
below A+ or without dropping below able
a
um it's hard to say with would I think
it will maintain it and that's that's my
my assumption I don't and to go below
double and to go below able a you got a
feel for that I mean you you you're
educated guess is going to be better
than my completely uneducated guess I'm
just trying to get a feel for what the
head room is and I promise I'm not going
to then try to fill it I just wa I would
just wa to understand can we not that in
a
minutes I think Andrew's probably got a
bit feel for it than what I I think I
might try and save Patricia a little bit
from that one I I think the true answer
to that is it's not that binary it's one
of the factors and I think the key that
what you're saying what Patricia is
saying is that they can see in the
forecast we've got a plan they agree
with that plan the debt goes up to that
because that's consistent with the plan
I can tell you the last time we went on
negative watch was when we threw a whole
heap of debt in without having a plan
and that that rattled fit more so than
the level of debt they were concerned
around the decision- making process and
how we got to the decision of doing that
without it been in our forecasts and and
that was back 1670 and so it's a range
of factors and You' see other councils
that are AA that 've got much more debt
than us but it's that decision making
process and the certainty that gives
Fitch the confidence that you can manage
those
levels Tom your growth your growth
counts in North Holland are probably at
285 with those S these sorts well no not
no this is a very good rating but but
with a level of rating although some of
those are on negative watch Leslie you
think you had a question it's not a
question it was just a comment that the
other factor that F would probably look
at was if we drastically altered our 20
million cash for reserve line I would
think that would cause them a bit of
um hesitation thanks ly I'd really
encourage you um in time um as you go
through your ltp to look at Pages what
is 22 and
23 and 2 24 actually of of our agenda
which is the which is summarized as the
key rating drivers Tom um now it's tied
up on a bit of um rating Orthodoxy uh
and thinking but it is reflecting the
the drivers that would impact us and it
goes exactly back to Andrew's point but
it's not just what debt cap we might
have but there is a whole range of
factors like the quality of our spend
our ability sorry our preparedness to to
rate
appropriately um there are a couple of
drivers there and I don't know what an
SCP means do you um in terms of their in
terms of their stuff Patricia um over on
I should find it for you um but the
things also on page 25 like the net debt
to operating balance which is actually
quite critical you read the drivers they
say if that gets up to seven they're
going to they're going to knock us back
a cog So within the report there is some
useful um uh detail about actually how
our credit rating would drive if we made
certain decisions but it reflects um EX
ex L Andrew's point you got to take
about you know 10 different things into
account here it's almost like a matrix
isn't it it's actually how they might
view the number would move the SCP is
the Standalone credit profile thank you
okay righto so look that's that that
that is actually really um useful one of
the things that I took out of it sorry
I'm assuming I haven't got any other
questions right the just one okay I'll
come back to you if it's okay Noby is is
indeed um uh take way message I took
from this is um we control this credit
rating through our own financial
management practice and that goes back
to Andrew's point it goes back to
Patricia's Point that's inside the paper
um and where we need to be cognizant of
these limits and the way that you're
asking the question Tom it's actually
really really important and it assumes
that we're they keep using it that we're
flexible in our thinking which
essentially means we'll keep ourselves
within the parameters of good Good
Financial
improvs Noby sorry you've got just just
one issue um just for those are probably
listening and um people often get
confused when they talk to me about
what's their debt position they the 150
180 that Patricia was talking about is
percentage isn't it it's not 150 or 180
million um and and the beauty of that is
it's 150 of
Revenue and of course if you can
increase your Revenue you have the
capacity to increase your um level of
borrowing without losing a rating so
that's a challenge from my colleague to
my left who keep saying that we need to
have more
Revenue but it is an option yeah we do
need to have the revenue to pay for the
interest
cost and and and the cash flow to to
meet the principal
repayments sure but revenues not not
just rate increases over no no that's
right considerably other my argument we
have another Revenue problem not a rate
not a rate problem yeah um look at a
fear Point um uh what I think is
relevant um is that
actually uh um for local government our
debt position is related to our Revenue
not our
assets because if you look at the asset
leverage we are very low we're about
7% but it actually comes back to the
revenue side which is the the net debt
to revenue ratio which becomes really
important okay thank you for that that's
that's really help I mean let's let's
firstly say Well done I mean our rating
is good I just wanted to raise the point
about the interest rate cover breach I
don't know why it's stuck struck on me
for the first time um the bancor report
which is the second appendix notes at
the moment are very low cost of debt I
think it's about 2.98 98% 3.98 it's the
only Council I know I can't say I can be
comprehensive in my engagements where we
are below 3% most are in the high fours
so we are in a very advantageous
position at the moment uh but as the
debt rolls
matures um your paper has indicated the
nature of the increases we are going to
face so I presume this is all been I
mean we've it's in our assumptions I
presume it's been fected into our LT ltp
Financial model but no different to a
household having to roll its
mortgage house what will change your
views around covering uh the the
interest rate cover
Gap
um at the moment I'm just waiting for
some the markets have been going up and
down we're trying to see whether we've
got some more level of certainty we are
at a point where we're probably looking
either between now and Christmas of
covering that
um there's the uncertainty through the
world markets at the moment and until
we've got a government we were just
holding off um getting that one we
haven't taken cover in a number of years
and there's a lot of admin associated
with uh getting covered again
truth we'd achieved it I think if I
recall correctly through taking fixed
rate debt um in the in the years of low
in the years when our rates were
we've effectively been taking fixed rate
is in contrast is in contrast to
floating rate and then fixing it using
derivatives where we probably need to go
to now is by taking floating rate debt
and um then fixing it um we have been
taking a lot of commercial paper um
until we've got some certainty and
that's predominantly backing up the ICL
loan is the back to back with that is
commercial paper so that is floating
right and that's just but it's shortterm
right until we've know what we're doing
with that loan can I just um uh Point
members to page 37 to 63 which is uh the
graphs out of the B cour report and uh
you'll notice on the left hand column
there a the breach which is on the top
the top um DET and cover uh diagram and
you'll see that um uh that headwind what
I call the headwind um interest rate
projection proposed you can see it
climbing for us when we renew um and if
you look over back one page to 36 you'll
see the main bar diagram shows our debt
maturity which reflects how that
interest rates could be affected as we
go forward Grant I just want to have a
discussion across the table I'm a we bit
we know we're sitting here with the
interest rate cover breach I take it
your finance committee is aware of this
or we don't need to pass any information
on to anybody else no we we discuss it
all the time great okay and it's facted
into the long-term planning and with
some of the other decisions we have been
thinking about around
um you know funding a um Capital program
um how we do that
with keeping our Revenue in line which
doesn't affect their borrowing capacity
but equally um you know some of the
assets we may have that may be Surplus
to requirements and how we can leverage
and utilize those more um fully to to
maintain a risk profile fund their
capital progr
and um yeah not reach a regulatory
obligations around some policies so yeah
look i' um patrier I'd like to add a
second resolution to our to our
resolution so we receive the report I'm
comfortable that the second one is I I
would like a report back at our next
meeting on um either how we've covered
the gap or what what the plan is um you
know you can over you can over rate you
over raate a risk um but we are in
breach of what is a potential cover
we've got advice that we are I'd like to
make certain that we follow this
carefully as a committee yes Michael
yeah through yourself CH if um in that
report you might want to um question the
policy bands themselves and actually say
do we actually challenge the bands in a
high-risk um economic environment
whether you actually have the right
bands in place um that's been the
challenge with the breach at the moment
is addressing the breach you need some
more stability in the Financial Market
we're not in that position at the moment
so therefore we're we're being risk
averse in relation to actually placing
cover yeah and that's then brings in the
question is the policy ban right have is
the 25% actually right for us do we need
to lower that because we're being less
risky in relation to what we're placing
out forward cover so um if you're going
to put that into a report may I suggest
that you include a a review have we got
the right policy band in place that's a
very hot point you always look at the
assumptions on which the actual the
actual C sorry the actual um credential
limit is based so I'm very comfortable
we include that that and I mean that's a
of M should be advising us on so and I
have already given miles of heads up
that we need to have a look at that
policy so my my intention in having a
second resolution that we get a report
back is just that we monitor that
whether that's a whether that's policy
ban effect or whether that's uh we take
cover or we
do something else um I'm I'm relaxed but
as long as we maintain it while while
we've got a policy BRD I'm going to be
uh
worried okay um so look we've sort of
lost the r the resolutions there just
I'm typing it just Ty up can I for the
sake of it I think we we've got a clear
sense of where the the second one's
going so I'll move from the chair that
we receive and that we seek a report
back at our next meeting on the on the
interest rate cover thank you Leslie
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say I I I those against it's
carried thank you very much so we dealt
with audit New Zealand can
we then deal with the long-term plan
decision making risk Rand are you going
to get up front to I wonder whether it
might be useful I looking at the paper I
suspect we need both so thank you thanks
Andrew we're in your
hands um I'll take the report as R and
we've touched on many of the things and
it was interesting uh to have a look at
that interest rate graph because I think
that tells you a number of things in
terms of you're thinking about what's
happening with the long-term plan I mean
not only as recorded by Fe and discussed
here interest is your borrowing going up
but you're also putting your interest
rates up by 2% at the same time and that
flowing straight into your operating
expenses and so there's a whole heap of
pressures as sort of highlighted in the
paper that are coming through around
your decision making around things that
are for one of a better description
already embedded into the decisions uh
that are going to continue to have have
impacts as we go through the the 10
years I suppose the point of this paper
is really to reflect before we get into
the audit and before we finalize our
consultation document the purpose of the
long-term plan and whether or not we
think the process that we're put in
place to control our compliance with
that purpose and to ensure that we
engage appropriately with the community
on all the issues that we're considering
have achieved that result that we're
looking for um and just highlighting
that
it has been a well thought out process
it has been set out and we have gone
through it but are we at the point where
we're going to come under pressure which
we are uh and will will the process for
one of a b description maintain its
Integrity to ensure that we're achieving
the right outcomes and that's really a
theme that comes through across a lot of
the papers today around as much as we
might hate it it's process I mean local
government lives on process to ensure
that we do these things properly and in
the way that we're supposed to um in
terms of achieving the outcomes for the
community so that's really what this
paper is trying to
highlight don't know if Ran's got
anything to
add i supp f um very interesting paper
and I oh sorry sorry just one more point
you you'll see there's a slight change
and so and this is me effectively
putting the asset on you I mean your
role as the risk and insurance Committee
in that that last resolution I mean do
we think this is achieving the process
as achieve the outcomes we're hoping to
achieve or do we need to do something
differently or more or less uh because
again it comes through time and time
again we're we're reviewing a process we
should review the residual risk rating
has the process controlled the risk the
way we expected it to and so this is
asking for some confirmation around that
as to whether or not there's anything we
need to do
differently thanks Andrew I think I got
that message and and and um to um
perhaps help us go through process I do
think we should just look through the um
uh the six risks and the residual rating
and control Effectiveness that you have
outlined on pages 58 and 59 of
63 um uh but before I do that are there
any comments or questions folk would
like to make yes
Tom it one issue I think it seems to me
is that I'm sure that whenever there's
been long-term plans done in the past
there has always been
almost an equal level of uncertainty as
there is today there is always dat about
the future and and it seems to me that
one of the problems with long-term plans
is their
inflexibility that when we say we need
to change some direction because you
know circumstances have changed um we do
as Council often get the comment I it's
in a longterm plan you know you cannot
change I I I mean I don't if this is a
time to discuss that but I wonder if we
I would like to understand understand a
little bit better the inflexibility
around long-term plans given the fact
that there are a number of unknowns
about the next 10 years um and in making
a long-term plan we know for absolutely
certain circumstances will change um and
the long-term plan as it exists today
will change we'll have to change it'll
be undeliverable may be better um
because things will things will change
but that inflexibility is the thing
that's always concerned each here and I
wonder if
you may comment on that because we have
various mitigations and you know some
are orange um so you know there are
risks which means that we have to be
able to respond when circumstances
change but the ability to respond when
you've got a 10-year plan is a bit the
concerns
me look through chair was was
interesting I mean and again this sort
of reflects my experience with local
government when I first started was with
long-term plans and and and there's two
parts and I think that what you're
really feeling is in flexibility is
really it was interesting looking back
at when it came in part of the reason
was too almost it gave local government
more things it could do and and Bruce or
someone who was around at the time might
have a better idea than me but the
tradeoff
was I was the tradeoff was that you had
to be more uh avert in your discussions
with the community and so the
inflexibility in changing is not uh that
you can't change it's that you need to
go back to the community and explain and
have the conversation as to why it's
changed and so it's not yes it's a one
of a better description a clunky process
but it's not that you can't change it's
just you need to be able to go back to
the community and explain we made these
set of assumptions we followed this
process made these decisions these
things have turned out very differently
this is why we want to change it and
have that conversation and that that is
the trade-off that they gave when local
government got more power to do things
you can have more power but we will make
you talk to your community more and
that's what the long-term plan process
is really
driving okay that's helpful thank you's
got a I think just to give a really
practical example it's why every report
that you receive that's around decision
making has the Strategic implication
section and the manager talks to whether
it aligns or doesn't align with the
long-term plan and as Andrew says it's
then really around triggering the
significance and engagement policy at a
higher
level Darren I'll be concern yeah it's
it's an echo it's not that the ltp is
inflexible it's just a process you have
to go through in order to flex and it
depends on the degree of flex that
you're wanting to make as to whether or
not you've got to go back to the public
and
consult going into the last long-term
plan nobody made provision for a
pandemic didn't stop
us
thanks right I wonder if we could um
look at page 58 Andrew and 59 because
this why one there's one um strategic
risk noted there um look let's you look
at I look at the know the question that
you've posed for us and it comes through
in the resolutions are we comfortable
with the residual risk are we
comfortable about the controls in place
and are they effective um so I do
actually just want to devote a couple of
minutes to actually just whipping
through these I wonder Ender if you
could start though with the second one
because that's where you've
highlighted um uh uh that the controls
in star view is defective or negligible
and I just wonder if we could have a
quick discussion about that
please and I think that goes the the
Crux of the issue that we we can't so
normally when you put in place a control
you're trying to change the likelihood
of something occurring and so it just
reflects the fact that we don't really
have a lot of control around changes
that central government might make uh we
obviously participate in in groups that
submit and all those sort of of things
and that's why we have that whole uh
work program where we do try and submit
to things that the government puts out
but in the end the government goes and
does what it does but it it this to me
more turns on this idea that uh the that
the paper touches on around uncertainty
as opposed to risk management we know
something will change uh and we can
measure the range of the impact of those
changes it doesn't make it uncertain it
just makes it risky and and the the the
risk we have is that when we get
confronted with with what is a risk
assessment we call it uncertain and
therefore don't make a decision whereas
we really need to accept that there is a
range of changes that might occur we can
measure the range of those changes and
make a decision that that takes a point
amongst those ranges so that's the I
don't think there's anything we can do
in this Bas to reduce the risk and I
think we acknowledge that but it it does
flow through to potentially having
impacts on our DEC decision making and
we can manage the risks around our
decision making by accepting that the
uncertainty is just a risk assessment
it's not something where we just say we
don't know what the government's going
to do therefore we won't do anything
because that is in itself as the paper
points out a decision and if we don't do
anything then we've made a decision and
we need to understand the implications
of
that and I would just note because I
went back to it because we did that good
work in the last meeting Andrew around
the consequence and you repeated the
table there I just noticed that the that
that we're saying that this is a this
uncertainty crystallizing is likely and
we know it I mean it's obvious but
actually the consequence could be major
which if I got it correctly could mean a
change in level of service could mean a
change in restructuring the organization
and or staff so the consequences are
pretty high related to this the reality
of it is is that as you're saying is we
don't necessarily have a lot we can
control over this we are a receiver
um which puts us in a residual risk
position that is challenging along with
the rest of the sector might I say but
it is challenging for us to do other
than some some scenario modeling or that
parameter range um and I would have
thought Chris's report uh about the ltp
audit with the two years of three Waters
and is an exact example with stally
that's correct but actually what is the
probable line at the moment we don't
know and that's that's the challenge yes
RNA so yeah just wanted to give like a
pragmatic example of how we've then
responded to that what Andrew is talking
about in relation to three Waters so
we've gone ahead and we've put the two
years into the budgets for the three
Waters however we've included the three
water decision making into the
infrastructure strategy even though
that's not legally required to reflect
that whatever happens we believe that's
really important context for the
community and we're going to attach the
addendums from the N which will give
that longer forward picture so that's
how we've tried to deal with that range
that you're talking about on that
particular issue it's really good I mean
and well done I mean I think that's I
mean it's not necessarily well it is a
control in the sense that we've allowed
for the fact what happens if we what
happens if the outside we own these
Assets Now the next next well
infrastructure strategies next 30 Years
um that becomes really really important
so that's encouraging to hear F any
other questions on that at the stage or
will we have a couple of the other ones
here just one of those other uncertainty
things around climate change was going
to chime in one of the things that the
government is looking at doing and it's
interesting that Chris was talking about
it is effectively prescribing the way
that we assess climate change risk um so
some of the the papers that are floating
around have a proposal whereby
effectively the assessment is is given
to us so that we don't everyone's using
their own assessment which is why you're
getting all the different results around
the risks uh they're going to prescribe
for local government this is the way you
are to assess climate change risk and
that will create that consistency across
the
sector thanks just have a couple of
comments without wanting to make this
sound like I'm extracting H teeth here
um effective relationship with key
stakeholders um uh interested me and and
Tom I reflect on the fun because it goes
back to potentially your comment around
the the climate change and the the the
regional working group actually are we
aligned becomes actually a really
interesting point um and I make no more
comment on that the other one Andrew
that I just want to give me a wee bit of
advice on please was the bottom one
which is that um the necessary
governance skills and experience um or
have conflicting priorities may can you
give me a a fish it out for me with you
please particularly around the
controls
it's it's that risk that we always get
and it's the risk to a certain extent
that that uh Council C alluded to where
we have differences of opinion and and
uh emphasis changes uh in the middle of
a process or after we've completed the
process and so the the the uh certainty
that we hope to achieve from uh the
process we've gone through in the
long-term plan decision making doesn't
hold and so you've got uh and it feeds
back into the top one as well and the
top one I threw in there around staff is
not necessarily one of the ones we call
out strategically but it's again to
council Campbell's point if we have to
go out and reconsult with the community
that's a big disruption and a big
Interruption to the normal ba program of
Staff uh and so it's it's that risk we
have all the time where uh for whatever
reason not saying it's a bad reason
necessarily but priorities change and
all of a sudden the guidance given to
staff and the work that needs to be done
to pick up those new priorities is out
of whack with where we already were and
I think it's I mean to be honest it
reflects a political risk um and that's
the environment we're in uh it's not
just this Council it's every Council uh
councilors come in or even midterm
priorities Chang um and it's it's
something that we need to try and manage
but it's recognizing it exists and part
of it comes back to an understanding of
uh of of fundamentally why we go through
the processes we do it is designed so
that the the community's taken along the
journey that all those things happen um
we're prudently using our funds and so
whil whilst it may be perceived as red
tape that certainty protects the
community from Big shifts in emphasis
that that ultimately cost the community
because we've wasted
money okay I think there's a strong
wrong sense the key control or controls
are particularly around
Clarity both on our thinking now before
we finalize the
model and and the outcomes and the
objectives we we are recording well and
I presume we are the the the rationale
for the position we've taken now because
I think we well know um uh that
uncertainty will mean we probably want
to change these we'll rather a as you
point there a future Council will have
to eventually look and change this they
need to understand why were we in this
place today making that call um so so
Clarity around the totality of our
intentions now being transparent to the
whole council is really important
Tom I think actually Andrew M have made
this point but it it seems to me that
the the greatest value that you get from
a long-term plan is not so much the
final document which you know is going
to be wrong you're not going to do those
things it's a process you've gone
through to develop that and the you know
the debates and the analysis and the you
know that's where the real value is it
seems to
me um right from the start um Tom um uh
right from
200 four when the first ltp said to come
out as Auditors we always said the only
thing we know about this plan it's
wrong which made you wonder about the
value of the opinion okay look that's
really helpful noi y um just as a reflec
and and building a little on what Tom
said earlier on I think um it's no
secret I don't particularly like
long-term plans I just think they set us
up the fail um and if I go back to the
um the last trianium I think we had four
or five projects at the front end that
we had to deliver we delivered one uh in
a delayed manner which we had to redo
which was the stuff at the pool and the
other four we didn't even start and so
that and if you look back you see the
that all the way through it's just a
wish list of things we like to do but it
sort of worries me and this is not
reflective of and but it worries me that
the
organization um gets to a stage where
it's um it's fear of
risk um or um it's adherence to a
longterm term plan and you see comments
like um the
governance skills and experience or
having conflicting priorities leads me
to believe that you you really want sort
of councils are just going to rub a
stamp everything it sits with a
long-term plan we don't change good
example we came in after the last
election and cancel a couple of projects
the city didn't go belly up when we did
that it was just reacting to the
environment that we faced and our
priorities changed and and I would have
thought that having a governance area
that um had conflicting priorities is
actually what democracy is built on
otherwise we go back to having a more
centralized process where
a a party of 10 councilors would stand
and they all be singing from the same
song sheet um that wouldn't be healthy
either so cheer if I can I don't think
Andrew's report criticizes that I think
it recognizes it yep I understand that
all I'm saying is that it seems to me
that the councils that have done well
around the country and I engag with some
of them um they are very Nimble they
have the ability to be quite flexible
respond very quickly
way up the risk of moving away from what
might be a long-term plan into something
else in an annual
plan this sort of tends to lock us in a
little bit I think that's just my
feeling of all that again cheer it
doesn't lock Us in it just says if you
want to change show there's a considered
process and in fact if if you've done
that and you've reacted to something it
shows the benefits of of being Nimble
and and smart but it is a risk because
sometimes and I'm not talking about this
Council I've seen decisions change
because of a new political will that's
that's come in that probably weren't
smart moves sometimes it's a sometimes
it's a a negative risk and sometimes
it's just a change that can happen
because it's it's right
to I think we have to take an Embrace a
view of the ltp and and and I would hope
uh and I'm not part either your
workshops or indeed your Council
meetings cleck but there is robust idea
you know competition of ideas if I can
it that that's democracy is the around
actually what goes into this ltp if I
can give a reflection to you having been
through every ltp since they came and
the discussions that are going on now
are the most robust I've observed good
well that's encouraging to hear Dar um
so look no not but but thank you because
I think that's actually really important
I think actually the ltp though Noby um
I don't want to mention the council um
but has been a significant driver of
organizational performance in other
words there has been that robust debate
and setting up the the what was now the
the 21 sorry the what are we 2131 ltp so
the last one to drive
delivery because actually the the the
the um the council settled on its
priorities and it has driven hard those
priorities I won't mention what it is I
might over a c te um but it's been
useful from that aspect as well
just going to do a formal reflection as
well which is around um
um in the the bottom end of that um
cluster there not the one that's on the
following page but the one that talks
about the government skills and
experience there's an interesting
comment there not in the best interest
of council and that that's a statement
it's own right for
me um because um when I think about how
we do our long-term plans and
Darren's quite right I've only sat
through two but certainly miles apart
this year this time from last time last
time was terrible we were getting to the
end of the last trium when we looked at
the longterm plan we had workshops with
two and three people here people just
got worn out by at all it just seemed we
put an awful lot of energy into
long-term planning and then don't seem
to put hell lot of energy into either
delivering it or alternatively of being
number one and being flexible as we go
along and so so um you know when we when
we get papers or that we put out to the
community and we get 200 back rate P
back com thing we get excited by 200 um
yet it's only
1% so I guess it's just it seems to me
it's very much driven by the quality of
the people that want to attend
workshops and not by those that sit away
from them and Mumble and Grumble as an
observation though Noby I think one of
the challenges we had with that last
long-term plan is that some counselors
were quite simply exhausted from the
whole working working together process
that they went through which just you
know it sucked a lot of time and and to
be fair it took priority because it had
to um and so when it got to the the
other end of the trianium people were
neing final question please to to um
Patricia here um well actually it might
be you Reon um page 63 of 63 the last
page of open Agenda we we I always IM in
the time table I know we we've got a
paper in PX and you maybe you want to
say I'll talk about it then but I shaded
the last box Tuesday the 28th of
November and it said those those five
really important things how are we going
on those um I'm sorry could you repeat
the page number page the last page 63 of
63 it's got the to it's got the it's got
the time the appendix to the paper it's
got the timetable and Tuesday the 28th
of November s me to be a key date yeah
so there's a this is a really important
Workshop um it is the final budgeting
Workshop ahead of the activity plans as
pessa said going to the December council
meeting um so um I guess this really
speaks to some parts in that Andre
pointed out in this report that we're
now coming to the crunch Point um this
whole program was really designed by
Council it was your strategic priorities
that set the first six months of the
program and that's flowed through into
all the technical documents that then
sit underneath um and now we're coming
to The Balancing Act that arrives in
every long-term plan process in terms of
finalizing where everything is going to
sit in terms of the budget so um
Patricia and the finance team working
really hard on that at the moment so is
a crucial Workshop um on the 28th um the
draft Financial strategy and
infrastructure strategy have already
been received by Council so we've done a
lot of that work and but now is about
making the final tweaks and getting the
final direction from Council to finish
the budgets brilliant I'm glad to hear
that's on track Ren and um I think when
I noted I wrote down this the sharp end
of the ltp plan so um I agree with you
entirely can we move to the resolutions
please and and in light of the
discussion we've had um uh let's just
look at it carefully we received the
report uh we note the difference between
decision making under uncertainty versus
risk and the implications and sorry
versus risk and the implications for
decision
making okay we've talked a lot about
uncertainty so I think we've got
ourselves here we confirm the
appropriateness of the current controls
to manage decision-making risks through
the long-term planning process and we
focused a weit on the residual risk
environment that we are in and we
confirm that the current residual risk
rating and um here's the critical thing
what do we do recommend not recommend
further action be taken to reduce the
residual risk we've got a decision to
make here fake anybody want to leave me
on this one yes Noby so um on page 61 at
the very end there's a statement that
says there is a risk that the failure to
appropriately identify and manage
strategic risk leads to a weakening of
risk management at
ICC and I guess that's not a statement
it's just saying if we don't do that my
worry that is we've had a good audit
this time with audit New Zealand um
we've got good internal controls in
place f is still saying they have
confidence in us um I I would not I
would not be considerate of doing too
much more in the r space I think we've
got that well cover compared to what I
hear
elsewhere yes
Tom I think flowing from the you know
risk analysis and the recognition
everybody has that it'll be wrong is the
extent to which you know that concept
that noi mentioned of being
Nimble is actually built into the
long-term plan
itself so in other words to what extent
do we actually reflect in a long-term
plan the the need to you know be
constantly looking at her eyes and
changing where it's
necessary I mean maybe that's in there
already but maybe maybe it's not maybe
it should be just actually more
explicit
yes Leslie thank you Mr chair um when I
looked at this particular recommendation
I thought if we were going to take the
recommend further action be taken to
reduce the residual risk we actually
needed to fill in a little bit more
about what what we were recommending
exactly if we go that
route at the moment that would be a
slightly meaningless phrase if we're
going to go that route my feeling is we
need to put a little bit more detail
about what further actions we would
therefore be talking about and at the
moment I'm tending to think we're in a
situation
where the watching brief of the not
recommend route feeling comfortable
presently with where we
are but knowing that we have a watching
brief brief on the possibility that
there might be further actions which
will
arise might be more where we
are have you got words you'd like to put
in there leslee if I could be blunt you
mean if we went down the recommend route
oh whatever route you'd like to
recommend you don't need them if you go
for not recomend well if if we well well
sorry I'm going to say if I could just
jump in the listening to Liz Le Dar and
I think she's saying um you know we've
had a discussion on the the risks at
least the ones that I've chosen to focus
on and we recognized essentially it's a
partially effective but we haven't
identified
other action that should be taken at
this point I think you're trying to
insert the difference between my feeling
is if we go down the not recommend route
we probably need to add some words but
with an ongoing awareness that there may
be further actions identified in the
future if we go down the recommend route
I think we would need to put in some
yeah steps definite further action steps
We Believe should be implemented now um
and I haven't necessarily worked out
some words for going down that route but
the not recommend rout I would say we we
put in something that refers to possible
future identification okay we have a
watching brief so got Darren then got
Grant and I think Michael would like to
make a comment did you want to make a
comment to R oh I wait for them first
okay so
Darren Grant dri and Michael we want to
jump in there too so at the stage I'm
going to not recommend and and I think
all we need to do is add at the end at
this stage or at this point which gives
you the flexibility
MH further on if there is a need for
further action to be able to respond but
at this stage we don't need to take any
further action thank you Darren Grant
yeah it's ambiguous and to the point
where long-term plan development so are
we talking about how we've developed the
long-term plan and we should we make
amendments to its residual risk or are
we talking about how that plan if it's
enacted would present risk to us I think
particularly around Finance it's not
clear it's the former which is actually
I've got it correct it's it's the former
and it's actually about going back to
those risk schedules on 58 and 59 which
is about the preparation decision making
around what is the long-term plan do we
need to have more controls in place
that's not clear but
that got R then I got Michael and I got
Tom Darren basically covered what I was
going to say so I like the way you're
thinking thank you through yourself
cheer um it's kind of a difficult one to
answer from um the se's perspective
because I've got a um public excluded
update in relation to strategic risks to
council for um reasons but um some of
those components um do refer to the
long-term plan and the impacts of the
mitigation steps we have in place but
um From perspective of putting a
recommendation or not recommending here
I think it's um difficult for Council to
make a call to provide
recommendations uh without actually
hearing that Brice so I think it might
be something that needs subject to um
the next meeting that you actually make
a call on if you want to make any um
recommend any mitigation steps post um
hearing the update and relation to
that right Noby yeah when I look back to
that schedule again on on pages four not
four and five of the
report I mean what we're getting signal
there is if we don't all of those
statements start with the word f IC f i
i mean I look at that cluster of six I
don't see major risks in most of those
areas I I think we'll see when we get
the health and safety report shortly
done some outstanding work in the last 6
8 n months in health and safety compared
to where we've been in the past so you
know that leads us to think that we've
got a whole lot of major risk that we've
now got to sort of mitigate as we go
forward yeah I just don't see that I
mean i' can't reflect Darren can but if
I reflect on the way the council's
currently working the way it worked last
time and and the subsquent involvement
of Dia just World apart so while while
it's all at the flag that if we didn't
do something but the question is are we
doing okay in most of those areas I
think we are people might have other
views on it which not recommen would be
the logical line okay anything else
people would like to say at this point
yes Tom sorry did I miss you out sorry
my apologies I think M actually was
going to be before me and up a ton did
you
Mel yeah yes I did yes oh you okay okay
um
look what I would actually like to see
as an additional light item is if IC
does not recognize change change
circumstances um I think if I look at
the the line items above it it is about
you know not doing the things that we
said but I think equally important and
it comes back to you know the point that
noi made earlier about you know being
prepared to change as if we do not rec
recognize the need for for change uh we
do not recognize change circumstances
and therefore they need to change the
plan to me that's an additional risk
item so I mean that would be um you know
recommend further action that' be the
further action that I would recommend
personally right I need a feeling of the
meeting I just wonder to um uh I'm
actually I'm looking at probably Michael
and Michael um is there a B for us to
actually hold this recommendation over
all we've heard from you
on through self
chair I'd be happy if from a council
perspective if it went with a not
recommend given the we've got the
actions in there because you'll be
getting an update in relation to what
the impact of those actions are from
myself um so you'll be able to reflect
on those in the next meeting to whether
you actually want to make any further
amendments um for us to make any
alterations on action during that time
frame will be difficult anyway um so it
would hold it over to say subject to
reviewing it the next next meeting well
I think that's exactly where Leslie is
trying to H us to and and Darren in some
certain sense to at this stage is that
we we are going down the line of uh not
recommended um further action to be
taken at this stage but subject
to uh new information and ongoing
review FOC there
mhm it seems to be okay it seems to be
the way to proceed right thank you I
wonder if we could do I need to wait for
you to type that up or can we can we
keep
moving so it's
not at the stage at the stage but but
subject to ongoing review
radio okay well like I've again done it
myself I better move the motion I have a
second P thank youle is there any debate
on the
motion been none I'll put it all those
in favor please say I I I those against
it's
carried thank you that gets us to the
end of the
um uh uh the Open Session I wonder if we
could just move to the resolution to
exclude the public before we have a
short break um we've got a number of
matters there that are on page three of
your agenda which are outlined as
scheduled for um PX with the
recommendations I'll move from the chair
that we move into PX for the reasons St
do I have a second please thank you Ria
is any discussion on the
motion being none I'll put the motion
all those in favor please say I I those
against it's carry brilliant look it's
uh oh my
clock